eh bien oui nous nous sommes avec aimé
jacquet et mais on vient de vous voir
sur les champs elysées est-ce que ça a
été la plus belle ou la plus longue
journée de votre vis à la plus forte
parce que tous ces gens qui viennent
vous remercier qui sont chaleureux
heureux qu'ils échangent un clin d'oeil
ou un petit signe de la main
c'est parfois je dirais réconfortant et
ça nous ça nous ça nous touche
profondément
on les voit tout cela derrière vous vous
allez rester amis c'est le terme jusqu'à
jusqu'à loin de votre vie il ne sait pas
sur terre mais on a tellement de
complicité on a tellement de temps passé
ensemble on a tellement échanger on a
tellement travaillé on a tellement
souffert on a tellement été ensemble que
cette page que nous venons de tourner
restera à jamais gravé dans nos mémoires
et on n'oublie jamais personne
al'inverse l'équipe brésilienne on la
disait miné de l'intérieur par des clans
et crs coco et que ça ça pousse a pu
faire la différence dans ce match
moi j'ai pas senti qu'elle était miné 1
c'est une équipe qui n'a peut-être pas
pu jouer son meilleur football qui a
peut-être pas pu danser match de finale
parce que a été redoutable dans le match
c'est un final peut-être qu'elle ne
s'attendait pas et l'équipe de france
aux ti aussi présente aussi sérieuse est
aussi performante
je crois que là-dessus nous avons
peut-être réalisé une des plus belles
prestations de notre football à chaque
fois vous nous avez surpris sur les sept
match toutes manières jolie france
la qualité et puis comme je vous l'avais
dit annoncé j'ai utilisé tous les moyens
et tous les toutes les forces de cette
équipe de france je sais que votre rêve
c'est d'emmener la coupe à sail sous
couzan votre village de natal est-ce que
vous allez le faire et quand où et on le
fera mais un peu plus tard parce qu'en
ce moment j'ai beaucoup de travail
chose promise chose due une dernière
chose
vendredi on connaîtra le nom de votre
successeur à la tête de l'équipe de
france je vais pas vous demander qui
vous souhaiteriez voir parce que vous
répondriez pas mais vous qu'est ce que
vous allez faire maintenant à moi je
vais retourner à la direction nationale
à la disposition du football de masse et
retrouver mon poste d'entraîneur
national dont on prendra plaisir à voir
revoir et merci pour tous ces beaux
moments de bonheur que vous nous avez
apporté tout au long de cette coupe du
monde merci mais c'est vous